Hello bitches honey,
y'all.
Yaz is tiny gentlemen.
He didn't meet,
I think he used to fight at
one 35 now he's won 25 right?
Isn't honey at one 30 he's the one 35
or one 25 not the biggest guy in the
world.
Find out what way it is.
I think he's a flyweight.
Now I might be wrong,
but anyway,
it doesn't look like a bodybuilder.
Anytime.
Oh,
dos Anjos caught him with that left high
kick and that's what I'm talking about.
Like he can,
he can add in.
Oh,
you don't know Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ Jesus.
He's going to win Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh my God.
Jesus.
This is fucking tremendous.
The at again,
this is hard against fuck
cops kill Joe Rogan is fucking
down.
Like,
oh Geez.
It control.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
but he don't know where he is.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know who he is.
This is hard and gets fucking skill.
Sakis I've been waiting
for this bucket pipe,
but three fucking months.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is what the fucking
problem is looking at you.
Every once in a while
you run into a brick.
Fuck the wall.
This Guy Diaz the fuck they did.
These people say,
look at his shit.
You got to kill this motherfucker.
Get over.
There's a new 55 where
it's got to McGregor now.
Where's kind of the Gregor?
Now this kit's Philadelphia.
You dumb mother fuckers.
Eddie Albert,
right?
This is crazy.
I told you,
this is the fight of the bucket here.
You fucking Momos holy
shop with your bullshit.
Brock Lesnar and mark fucking
hot daisy stuff compared to this.
God Damn
God Damn Eddie Alvarez.
I told you I was excited
when you called me.
This is the fucking fight of the year.
Cock suckers.
Holy Shit.
Eddie Alvarez.
She says,
I've got an anxiety attack.
He looks fantastic.
What I'm fucking talking about.
That was spectacular,
man.
150 rounds,
Joe Rogan fucking spectacular.
Look at this.
Boom.
That right hand landed there.
I think the legs go,
Oh shit.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Still again.
Wham.
O He snuck it in right over the guard.
Oh,
we did the chicken dance.
I'll tell you what dos Anjos,
he weathered a fucking dollar store.
None for those sign.
Use a fucking savage to Conor McGregor.
You better pack a lunch if you want
to fuck with these motherfuckers.
These motherfuckers told
you this is the deck five.
Oh my God.
Eddie Alvarez.
Look at these common
Merica fuck you when you're dumped.
Fight smart content.
Nitrous but the pocket.
Wow.
This was at Joe Rogan is boy Mark Henry.
That guy is one of the
best coaches in MMA today.
Dude from new geography.
Suck my deck.
You'll walk when you're fucking
machines and your bullshit.
I'm paid some fucking dude.
Suck my Dick.
And his other client was Frankie Edgar,
but heart,
they show up with nothing but hard.
Yup.
And I'm a big fan of Henry's big fan.
Fucking tremendous
winner by Tko new one 50
are you fucking kidding me?
This just throws a tremendous
wrench into everything now.
Well you know what else it does?
It lets everybody know
how fucking God damn good.
Michael Chandler and I
told you on the phone,
Joe Rogan,
he came in,
he looked through bots.
The first fight he bugged Gilbert,
the other guy.
All the first five is
a slow fucking starter.
It's over now.
Well,
the first fight,
a lot of pressure.
First of all,
you know,
first fight in the UFC,
his career's on the line,
you know,
leaves Bella tour as a champion.
But it shows you how good do you see
how good Michael Chandler looked in his
last fight?
They,
these two had wars over
and star wars and Chandler,
uh,
just knocked out pit
bull in the first round.
Damn.
Eddie Alvarez look good.
I looked fucking tremendous.
I've got an anxiety attack.
Joe Rohde.
What's my guys?
What we're saying like the Eddie
Alvarez is the kind of guy occasion.
This is the shit we forgotten.
There's no,
you'll see tattoos on him
or a gold P and was at that
mother fucker all fucking hot.
And the animal man,
he hits hard to look at that.
Boom.
Oh Shit.
Dos Anjos took some,
Nah,
they'll sign.
Yes.
Oh my God.
Anybody else would have went down by now.
20 guys would have went down by now.
Fucking Eddie Alvarez.
He's a good dude.
It's just thanking all the people who
trained to look at this great guy,
man.
Good for him,
good for him,
and great for the sport to great,
great guy,
great for the sport.
Really Likable Guy.
Really marketable guy.
Good for him.
Good for him,
man.
You know what dose on Joe,
so he'll be back now sets up some
interesting folks though that being gone,
I now you got this,
this,
this throws a monkey
wrench into everything,
but you ain't beating this kid.
You Ain't beating this kid for
the next two or three fights.
Alvarez.
Yeah,
you ain't beating him.
This kid is a fucking Philadelphia guy.
He's been eating pizza for 20 years.
He's done.
You're going to give him a lobster tail,
docking lights out,
lights out,
pitch.
I wonder if he gets a number.
Give Madoff gets a shot at him next.
I wonder if that's what they set up.
You know,
it's hard to deny Nima
Grumet off his shot.
He's undefeated and he's
the number one contender.
This showroom.
This is beautiful.
What?
Beautiful right hand.
He snuck it in there,
man.
And he saw him do that chicken dance.
That's crazy that he didn't go down,
man.
No,
no,
no.
And you caught the punches.
He got hit with Oh,
bombs.
This is fucking Carlos condit
jr he got hit with bombs.
He's just teeing off on him.
Herb Dean best in the
business right there.
He just looks at,
he's like,
Yep,
I seen enough.
I've seen enough.
And I totally agree.
Perfect.
Time to stop it.
Herb Dean is the best.
He really is.
Who you're breathing heavy cheeses.
You okay with that?
I'm just getting anxiety though.
For Real.
Yeah.
Cause you get worked up.
I love this shit.
This is my life,
but I love my business.
I saw,
Hi Dawn.
This is hard.
That was hard.
That's hot dog.
That's not you.
What do you think?
You hang out with your boys and drink
non gluten and he loses his shit.
He fucking,
you know.
[inaudible]
okay.